ayant tout le monde s'est excusé
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur roccat et
que c'est un jeu qui mélange un match de
foot est un jeu de voitures voilà qu'en
fait c'est un match de foot avec des
voitures c'est parti on va jouer en mode
de v2 donc voila en gros chacun joué une
voiture il ya une balle au milieu et le
but c'est de mettre la balle dans les
cages adverses
bon voilà un match de foot quoi c'est un
petit peu mad max version foot vallon
divers moyens au niveau mondial tu joues
tu fous là ont présenté des emprises et
sa flore ayant offert on est bons hop il
tire comme ça et moi et moi je suis pas
là on a un double saut comme voulait le
voir et de la nitro à ramasser
voilà dégagement attention sa blague
plus haut non non j'ai cru tomber la
balle flory floridien flory hasard flow
rillettes mal et mon nuls à ça c'est moi
ça valait le conte qui fait une passe
décisive c'est moi je suis là je suis
lui prévu pas non j'y arrive pas je
n'arrive pas je suis à florian tu la
mets tu la metula mais je ressens tu
ressentes florian nez trop long il y à
deux partout il reste trois minutes 21
de jeu a alors ça mais non si là mais
j'ai honte je mets du kanye west c'est
parti
fb je mettrai plus jamais dû kanye west
the right man
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que je
fais mais il me pousse pas j'ai paniqué
non c'était ma chance il l'a saisie
dégagent des gaz non mais c'est sérieux
ça n'a pas souri
flory fleury flory floride florida dès
lors il pas baissé de 20 jeux non je ne
sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit ça est vrai
la passe décisive à lui-même pour qu'il
la remette
voilà c'est un joueur égoïste qui joue
perso je vous perso c'est pourquoi
puisqu'il est payé à chaque but flory
nous reste qu'à 32 secondes pour deux
buts face à fleury il a explosé c'est
pas grave floridis gros enfin aux voix
elle revient jamais soyez de fleurs et
vs aaa
cerise sur le gâteau ah bah ça va alors
ce n'est une souris le mans tout va bien
quitter vers menu principal autrement
appelée racheter de la lose
par contre d'avoir suis champion de
france de 3v 3 je vous le dis à mes
l'avons pro d2 mais vous allez voir à la
t il à un témoin là on aurait dit luca
au charme
ohlala alors ça c'était beau c'était mon
peu mais pourquoi il pas le monde put
faso n'est pas décisive seuls les vrais
joueurs les fonds la regarde derrière
moi j'ai voulu voler un but à l'évêque
qui joue sa vie on y va on y va on y va
aussi falloir on y va au menace on et
d'hazebrouck cela on y naze et le but
contre sochaux il ya les gardiens chez
le piège super d'europe
mon dieu le public étant [ __ ] là je
fais une vidéo je perds tous mes matches
voilà juste avant j'étais champion
d'europe mais c'est vrai elle est à nous
elle à nous elle y va et les bains non
hélas au nom tirs cadrés +30 elle y
allait vraiment comme si le jeu doivent
être été de nouveau 6 5 2 1 à oliva lima
yves à la dérive à elle y allez vas-y le
jeu il est contre nous débloquer des
stickers crâne
ah bah ça va alors que c'est pourquoi on
a perdu parce que normalement je suis
juste champion d'europe du cadre des
quatre c'est parti ça commence direct on
y va
comment saclay nord comme à marquer mes
fils de chien technique du retrait
technique du regret au prince ce
dégagement au on est tous les uns sur
les autres les gars là ok on va
construire m'a construit achevé sur
l'ailé gauche là on construit là ont
construite shon ai marre de voir gagnant
bleus j'en ai marre de voir dans la team
on a des pneus bombasse aval comme c'est
pourquoi on a encore perdu en fait on
note préféré c'est simple c'est le un
contre un c'est parti mais ce dernier
est tombé contre raïssa fc 2000 voilà un
homme qui vient des années 2000 qui vit
dans le passé
ouais ouais heureusement j'étais contrer
parce que moi aussi je suis très fort je
suis champion d'europe inverse je n'ai
pas menti à banon
oh la la comment on le mène en bourrique
comme dirait ma mère est le but
il n'a pas du tout aimé ma balle le
ballon doit alors faire mais on fait la
même
es-tu l'art est celle là bas non c'est
pas quoi faire le mec
regardez bassar autre nom tir cadré ils
étaient pas cadré ah ouais ok j'aime
bien donner à un petit peu un avantage à
mon adversaire voit les champions
d'europe font ça régulièrement ok mais
non mais le même sens bien pile dans mes
buts quoi tu avais combien je vis très
au lycée pour avoir d'alarmant bleu
parfait comme ça
c'est mature ça comment j'ai pu rater ça
un pardon
en fait je n'ai pas raté et si on fini
premier au bon accueil remporte forfait
pardon il arrache kit baladins j'adore
les paladins balade à niveaux sont assez
drôle ça t'es mort il soit là 14t à nous
ça se produit vous allez voir
ouais
l'élève cavale groupe pour raser
d'ixelles seront produire j'ai pas dit
dans quel cas ok faut pas attendre trop
longtemps monty voilà du doigt après on
ignore ce qui se passe après ça tire et
ça va dans des cages à voilaaaâ merci
quoi ah ah ben on s'entend bien tous les
deux renards bon feeling on s'est dit
tous ces tristes labo tiens il s'est
passé quoi non non non non non non non
non non faux mais put non mais attends
si on fait le bilan calmement sa maman
chaque instant par les désiste en avant
comme si on avait 50 ans je regardais
quoi regarder ma voiture elle est
inactif pendant plus de dix secondes
voilà tu es mort c'est pas rentrer sans
déconner un [ __ ] non non tu es une
grosse merde in sous merde t'es la plus
grosse de toutes les mers d'europe aux
savantes ça bah ça rends toi là bas
alors battez pas là ça va dans ces
caches à s'asseoir dans ses cages
regarder olala l'attentât sauvetage
oh c'était bien joué ça va-t-il gagner
le titre
voilà moi tout ce que j'ai à dire c'est
que j'étais perdu voyant déchets plus où
j'étais je me trouve en abuse de voiture
il en profitait pour marquer je suis là
même souffle tamer ok alors tu me parle
pas comme ça je te plaît elle revient
leur antre garde se plaint petit dernier
un petit dernier à tanger avoir un truc
là moi je suis débutant lui c'est un
semi pro est bon on va battre le
semi-pro
c'est facile de marquer qu'on est seul
au but et qu'on est un semi pro 1ère
cours outre un des buts aura pour se
motiver et squeeze pour savoir à son
coach il se prit un but et santé que la
fin était proche que son coach et les
luttes et foncer la gueule mais ce que
je voulais les gorges et le brûler vif
grosse mer var je vous ai repris
confiance en lui après avoir marqué un
but
il fit alors ce qu'on appelle un groupe
de jeunes et dans le milieu et dialyse a
même avec son adversaire
avec en prime un surplus de confiance en
lui quelle bonne tête de [ __ ] le titre
de champion d'europe a été remis en jeu
je vous dis débutants bâti le matin
semi-pro sajoo c'est vers ça joue sévère
par là c'est bleu au rouge en
l'occurrence mr ho [ __ ] cross était
tellement drôle
non non non je ne fais pas partie à vous
en faites pas tout va bien se passer on
va vous avez dit d'europe on va gagner
on va gagner on va gagner
à ce moment précis twizy de son vrai nom
lucas hochart est très loin de se douter
de ce qui va se passer il va
effectivement faire le mouv le plus
dégueulasse de sa carrière on t'aimait
lucas pays
acculé
et
wada aimons comme si plus rien n'est
possible
puis on n'est pas super un des possibles
en début de la fin au début de la fin or
il sauve légaux il sauve l'honneur il
sauvera du tout mais une station indique
aussi de lâcher la trêve à gaza avait
fait mal aux gagnants orange gagnent en
orange 2011l'agence déjà pas de
cdisation roquettes lit que j'espère que
ça vous a plu
quelques années ce des peines et la
vidéo comme d'habitude moi ça m'a bien
fait marrer c'est un super g vraiment
amusant à jouer
c'est un peu ce qu'il est un peu rageant
tout petit peu beaucoup de bien mais je
pense que jouer en 4 contre 4 mais qu
avec des potes ça doit être hyper
marrant enfin bref un moment il faut
lancer l'outro il faut lancer le
générique de fin
donc merci d'avoir regardé qui fait bien
en vacances et on se retrouve très
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo tient
tout le monde pis